نحن نضع
أشد العقوبات على النظام الإيراني على الإطلاق ،
وتواصل إدارة ترامب
تكثيف ضغوط العقوبات ضد إيران
بينما تستمر الحكومة الإيرانية في
التحدي الآن في الجولة الأولى من
العقوبات ، وهو ما تقوله إدارة ترامب بشكل أساسي
هو أن أي
شركة أي دولة ترغب في القيام
بأعمال تجارية مع إيران لن
تتعامل مع الولايات المتحدة مما
كان له تأثير كبير على الشركات التي
ترغب في الاستثمار هنا ، وقد غادر العديد منهم
البلاد وقرر آخرون ممن
أرادوا الاستثمار هنا عدم القيام بذلك
هذا يعني الآن بالطبع
ضربة كبيرة للاقتصاد الإيراني ، فالكثير من الناس
عاطلون عن العمل هنا ، فالكثير من الشركات
ببساطة لن تستثمر في
إيران بالطريقة التي كان كثير من الناس يأملون أن
تلك الشركات ستفرض عليها مجموعة ثانية من
العقوبات  لقد فرضت الولايات المتحدة على
قطاع النفط والغاز الإيراني قطاع الشحن
وقطاعها المالي ، كما
أنه من غير الواضح مدى تأثير هذه الآثار
السيئة.  لكن
هناك الكثير من الناس هنا في إيران
يعتقدون أن الآثار قد تكون
هائلة ، وتحاول حكومة الولايات المتحدة
حقًا تحقيق شيئين من خلال
ضغوط عقوباتها من ناحية أخرى ، فهي
تحاول احتواء إيران هنا في
المنطقة التي توجد فيها واشنطن.  اتهام طهران
بمحاولة نشر نفوذها في
الشرق الأوسط الكبير هو الشيء الآخر
الذي نحاوله  تحاول أيضًا القيام بذلك هو
محاولتها جعل إيران متوافقة مع الكثير
من المطالب التي تفرضها الولايات المتحدة على الولايات المتحدة.  يقول
إن إيران بحاجة إلى التوقف عن تهديد
إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة.  يقول على سبيل المثال إن
إيران بحاجة إلى التوقف عن نشر
نفوذها في أماكن مثل سوريا أو في
أماكن مثل العراق ، كما
يقول الإيرانيون إنهم لا يمثلون تهديدًا
لهذه المنطقة ولكنهم
يقولون أيضًا إنهم لا يريدون ذلك.
مقيد من قبل الولايات المتحدة
فيما يتعلق بالإيرانيين العاديين ، فهم
موجودون بالفعل في معسكرين في هذه المرحلة
، فمن ناحية ، هناك متشددون يقولون
إنهم يريدون البقاء متحديًا ويقولون
إنهم يعتقدون أن العقوبات قد
تكون حتى فرصة لإيران  اجعل هذا
الاقتصاد هنا أكثر اكتفاءً ذاتيًا
ولبدء المزيد من السلع وصنع
المزيد من السلع بأنفسهم ، فأنت لديك
إيرانيون معتدلون وهم بالتأكيد
قلقون للغاية هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
الذين عادوا إلى إيران بعد الحلم النووي في 20
أثينا هنا من
الخارج  الذين فتحوا شركات هنا
وبدأوا الاستثمار هنا ومن
الواضح أن هؤلاء الأشخاص لم يروا أيًا من
آمالهم وأحلامهم تتحقق وهم
يخشون ذلك مع استمرار العقوبات
لزيادة الأمور ضد بلدهم
لتزداد سوءًا بالنسبة لهم في السنوات القادمة
وعلى الأقل في الوقت الحالي
ليس من الواضح ما إذا
كان هناك طريقة للخروج من هذا المأزق
الذي استمر لفترة
طويلة بين  الولايات المتحدة وإيران
[موسيقى]